his success is a finger pointed at
mainstream media saying you guys are
[ __ ] up mainstream media doesn't want
to admit that they would much rather
believe his success is an element of him
being able to weaponize racism misogyny
and homophobia and feed red meat to a
bigoted audience that's the way that
they can preserve their image of saying
no there's nothing wrong with us we're
doing an amazing job
coleman hughes welcome to the show
thanks so much for having me
what has the response been like since
you released your rap track because i
know that you've been rapping for far
longer than you've been writing but to a
lot of people this probably sounds like
finding out that sam harris has released
a diss track on someone that it runs
quite
quite counter to their perception of
what you are and who you are
yeah the reception has been awesome i
mean i've gotten so much good feedback i
think people
are receiving it the way that i meant
for it to be received and um it's it's
it feels great to finally be able to
converge my music identity and my public
intellectual identity because
you know like you said i've been doing
both for a long time
uh in my private life
but in my public life i've i've been
doing the writing and podcasting way
more than i've been doing music so it's
good to
finally show people both of these sides
of myself the track bangs as well it
slaps man it's really good thank you
really really good and you went to
ukraine to shoot some music video in the
freezing cold
yeah that that's where it was shot it
was um
in like uh
what would normally have been a kind of
circus as in for animals
uh in ukraine and it was not at all
heated it was in the dead of the
ukrainian winter so it was
basically like being outside
in the middle of a ukrainian winter
for like
12 hours two days in a row it was brutal
but that's the sacrifices you've got to
make man the sacrifices you gotta make i
ended up having a lot more respect for
actors
i had no idea the actual toll it takes
to
act several days in a row
in
conditions that are tiring and
exhausting
like these people
like i have no idea what they went
through to shoot that movie the revenant
with leonardo dicaprio and tom hardy but
my god the stamina it takes is
far
greater than you would assume from the
outside
i saw a behind the scenes of game of
thrones final season now say what you
want about narratively the way that that
show finished
but looking at the cast
sat down
on seats just waiting for their turn to
go as the film crew finally get the
lighting right they finally get the
camera angles right and they've run
through it and run through it and run
through it
it's the patience game i imagine that a
lot of actors develop a serious amount
of patience while they're doing that
yeah and you have to snap into the
emotion of the scene
when it's like
it's a totally sterile environment where
people are talking about lights and all
this blah blah blah yeah yeah and then
you have to snap into the ocean of the
scene and you gotta get it you know and
it's like
every minute costs a thousand dollars so
don't [ __ ] it up don't waste my time
it's it's incredible
what's your thoughts on this rogan
situation
so i guess there are two there are two
sort of waves of what's happened the
first wave was criticism in response to
his having robert malone
and peter mccullough
who said a lot of untrue
anti-vax misinformation
and because of that people like neil
young joni mitchell
wanted spotify to take him off off the
platform
and then
it seems like basically a week later
somebody you know strung together
examples of him saying the n-word
and unearthed jokes that uh
that make him look racist
obviously it's a these are propaganda
videos engineered to
make him look as racist as possible by
lifting something out of context
still they look bad
and basically it's just you know people
want his head people want his head on a
stick and
i am very against cancel culture i think
the way to engage people is to
criticize
the misinformation that they've
uh that that they believe i think joe
rogan is an extraordinarily open-minded
person
he has a relationship to correcting
errors and apologizing
that almost
no one else
in at his level of media has right he's
a person that can say i got it wrong
and does this often
in a way that is really credible and
honest and
really admirable because he's such a
genuine person he has such a
relationship to his audience where they
know he means exactly what he says
which you can't say of any of the cable
news people
that are reaching
um probably fewer people than he is
and because he has such a good
relationship to the truth even when he
gets stuff wrong
i think i mean it it's insane to people
that p to me that people are holding him
to a totally separate standard that they
would hold
uh you know a cable news show
all of which have also spread
misinformation to varying degrees
throughout the pandemic right
tucker carlson
says some [ __ ] or don lemon says
some [ __ ]
they don't have to worry
that their show is going to be taken off
the network
right whereas joe rogan because he
signed this deal with spotify partly
and because he's
frankly a lot of people in the
mainstream media i think are envious and
competitive of the amount of people he
reaches
and then a lot of people that don't like
the fact that he's not completely
left-wing obviously
um he gets hate from the mainstream
media
who don't really defend him as like a
fellow ally as someone we want to
protect because he's doing what we do
and then he gets hate obviously from the
canceled culture left
because he's not left
and i think i think it's it's it's
really dangerous i think we have to hold
the line for people like joe rogan
um or else we lose the norm of
free speech and i know the second you
say free speech people are going to say
it's not this is not relevant to the
first amendment the government isn't
trying to censor him
yes but
the reason the first amendment makes
sense is because of this wider point
that free speech is a very good thing
for society open discourse as a general
cultural
value is an important thing for society
and that means free speech for speech
you don't always like and i think that's
very important
what do you think about some of the more
right-wing commentators online that have
been saying
don't back down don't apologize for
anything this is not the way to play the
game
so
they would be right for a lot of people
it you know these days it does not make
sense for a politician to apologize
no one believes it
biden apologizes no one believes it
trump apologizes well he never
apologizes
but if he did no one would believe it
because
you know imagine hillary clinton
apologizing does anyone in the world go
oh my god that's amazing that she can
see
that she's evolved so much as a person
no it's it's so clearly scripted right
and frankly i think
any apology from normal media figures is
going to seem scripted
the difference with joe rogan is he this
is the joe rogan effect right
his apologies
are real
you can you can just hear it you can see
that he
he really thinks he should have had more
people on from a provac's perspective
um
he is doing his best and
his apologies are
he's one of the only people at his level
of media reach that can apologize in a
way that does not seem scripted and
seems credible
and
as as a human being i think the ability
to apologize is extremely important
and that holds for your friends that
holds for your relationships
and it should hold if you have a really
honest relationship with your audience
with which joe rogan does to an
exceptional degree so i disagree with
those i think his apology came across
extremely well
i think that
there's definitely a a different element
to when joe apologizes versus when other
people do it i think the concern from
people on the right is that
by
apologizing you lend credence or
legitimacy to people that want to
censor free speech right
but joe is doing his apology in a very
different sort of way because of the
level of intimacy that he has between
himself and his audience and the amount
of trust
the thing that i think that's
interesting is usually when the
mainstream media try to attack somebody
with um clips whether that be from the
like first phase of this uh campaign or
the second phase of this campaign around
covid versus the eclipse of him saying
the n-word
i think that
the problem that they have
most of the time the press are trying to
show you a small microcosm of someone
that they claim is indicative of the
remainder of their character right here
is the tip of the iceberg
that shows that this person is the
racist homophobic xenophobic whatever
that we always knew that he is and
here's the proof this is the cracks
showing in his persona and this is the
actual true joe coming through you just
didn't happen to know about it the
problem that you have is that the vast
majority of people even people who are
super duper casual fans of rogan have
probably listened to at least 100 200
300 hours and the normal fans of him
you're talking upwards of a thousand
hours easily that someone can have
consumed joe rogan's content they go
well hang on a second i i can't take
this is the tip of the iceberg from you
the whole iceberg precisely i have such
a depth of connection with this guy
they've seen the tip and the bass
correct that sounded really weird do not
say that again pause
the tip in the base of joe
but yeah
that's it that's what they're trying to
do they're trying to use this old media
narrative of here is the
small segment that represents the bigger
version uh but they can't do that they
can't do that anymore
yeah so it
you raise a really interesting point
and i think it's true
what separates this cancellation from
most other cancellations
is that they're not unearthing anything
there's nothing
we all know exactly who joe rogan has
been
for years now because
he has four hour conversations every day
that are completely unfiltered
where he says exactly what he thinks
right
all the evidence of him being a bad
person
if such evidence exists it's already in
the open
right there's nothing to discover
if you hate him you hate him based on
who he actually is by now
but
so compare that to like a different kind
of a cancellation
you know
generally it's it's like finding
something no one knew about right it's
like
we found this blog from 15 years ago
where joy reed from msnbc
said that you know all gay men like
underage boys right that's a true that's
a true story that happened people don't
really talk about it because
since
joy reid is a darling of the left she is
somehow immune to the logic of
cancellation
even though if joe rogan had done the
same thing people would be foaming about
foaming at the mouth about it which
again as a sidebar shows you how these
sort of cultural rules are used as
um basically
totally arbitrary rules to [ __ ] over
people you don't like and you suddenly
stop caring about them when it's
something you like that should tell you
everything you need to know about these
cancellations for things you said 20
years ago
i mean someone unearthed something of
neil young saying
something like pretty
i think it was kind of pro nazi i might
have to fact check that but he said
something really cancelable in like the
80s or 90s
and then he walked it back
um
but you know that
that's usually how cancellations work
it's like
this thing oh you didn't know roald dahl
said basically justified the holocaust
right and now you know and it makes you
think about matilda differently okay
that's usually how it works even in
those cases if a person has disavowed
their views i'm really against
cancelling them because people change so
much over the course of their lives
the difference with joe is that that's
not what's happening here it's like
they're just stitching together
non-representative out of context bits
from a long career
and playing them back to back as if all
he's been doing for the past 20 years is
saying the n word do you know where that
do you know where that super cut
originally came from
aware
alex jones made it
no way
alex jones made it
why do you remember when he him and
rogan had that beef
no
okay so him and rogan had a fallout a
little while ago it was like semi-public
it was before spotify maybe
i want to say five or four or five years
ago uh and this was alex throwing a
little bit of shade around in an
original version of this video now i
might be i might have been sold a lie by
the version of the video that i've seen
and if that's the case then sorry alex
but
uh it's i've heard from a bunch of
different sources that the original
video was from alex jones and if you
actually look at the first first first
version it's got infowars graphics on it
and this was him throwing that around so
the interesting thing i'd seen this
video
a bunch of times it's been floating
around twitter for quite a while and
i've seen it i've seen it do the rounds
a fair bit but there's equivalent
versions of this for the young turks
there's a huge one of them floating
around at the moment that's got one and
a half million plays on it they're just
same thing out of context n word n word
n word n word n word there's uh ethan
klein when he tried to when he deleted
some of jordan peterson's episodes with
him a couple of weeks ago he said both
the n-word and the f-word back-to-back
over and over again
i really love saying
did any like
okay
but then the supercut of joe
for whatever reason
decides to really really get a lot of
momentum and gravitas now one of the
things that i definitely don't think is
true that i've seen in a bunch of
different group chats i'm in is that
this is part of some overarching
conspiracy there's some company the one
that's behind patriot takes which is the
twitter account that did it they're in
support of some other super pac
organization that is linked with blah
blah blah and uh
stool presidente who's the guy that owns
bar still sports
dude that owns barstool sports went on i
know i know who you're talking about
went on a
livestream podcast with the guys that
own that company that is associated with
this and he's going backward and forward
i don't think that there's i don't think
you need to look to conspiracy to see
why these two things happened in
um sequence with each other especially
if
as i said this video has been floating
around for a long time and it wasn't
created by somebody i think that you've
primed the uh like cultural algorithm
with joe rogan's done something wrong
and he's done an apology video and then
people have taken this opportunity to go
right okay now i'm gonna try and throw
yeah precisely
what have we got yep what else can we
throw at him there's videos floating
around of
other stuff as well uh are you not gonna
everyone's talking about joe rogan's
racism but what about his misogyny here
he is laughing at one of his comedian
friends saying that he used to get
sucked off in the back room of the
comedy store
and it's just what can you find over a
twelve years
yeah i know uh over a 12 or 15 year
career of having whatever
10 hours of conversations a week like 2
000 podcast episodes um
but it's hard it's hard to say
it's not the individual words in context
the way that you do that it's not
forgivable or at least it's not it
shouldn't be like something that we
support but as somebody that puts out an
awful lot of content i know that as your
volume increases you're gonna say dumb
stuff over and over and over again and
uh over a long enough period of time
there's going to be a lot of dumb stuff
and that's how you make like a huge
supercomputer if you're a comedian
that's often having other comedians on
your podcast drinking smoking weed on
your podcast it's an informal
conversation
they're not putting together
uh you know like you know 99 theses of
like what they think about the world all
the time a lot of times they're [ __ ]
around that's why people like it
um
you know listen i think we have to also
talk about
the issue of whether it is
in all cases immoral or unethical
to say the n word
right
people are i think pretending not to
understand the difference between
mentioning a word in quotations
and
directing a slur
at somebody right with malicious intent
those are two very different things and
it's two very different people
that do either one of those
and i think people are disingenuously
pretending not to know the difference
between those two things pretending not
to be able to observe the difference and
you know it's so interesting i
finally watched the o.j simpson
documentary
um last week
and
there's this moment in the o.j simpson
trial
where
there's this huge fight over whether
they can admit
mark furman's n-word tape right this
this cop that got that found the glove
at the scene had a history of saying the
n-word
the oj's defense said we want the jury
to hear him say the n-word so that they
don't trust his testimony right
and the prosecution said we don't want
them to to hear the n-word right it's
going to bias their judgment and there's
this argument about it
and and the prosecution says
essentially to the judge when black
people hear the n-word they cannot
remain objective
it's too emotional
it's too
it's too hard-hitting
there's no black juror can remain
objective after hearing that word and
jurors need to remain objective
then oj's defense comes back and says
how dare you say black people can't
remain unbiased after hearing the n-word
how dare you it's racist it's
patronizing it's condescending
and they were widely thought to have won
that particular argument right back in
the 90s
the version of 90s woke that
that obtained during the oj trial said
of course black people can hear the n
word in certain contexts and understand
it and remain objective right remain
unbiased remain rational
what i find interesting now is that
people are implicitly making
the argument of the prosecution now
as woke which is that if black people
hear the n-word it's it hurts too much
we can't possibly remain rational enough
to observe the difference between
someone mentioning it
in quotation marks
and somebody directing it as a slur
of of course people can
and i think
you know this is where the cynicism
comes into this it's like
the notion of black people taking
offense at rogan saying this word
is
i think being used cynically to take him
down do you not think that any black
people have taken offense at it oh sure
i i definitely think some black people
have taken offense at it
um probably
black people that are less familiar with
him
right like if this is this goes back to
the iceberg question
if this is the tip of the iceberg that
you're seeing joe rogan about you're
gonna think he's a racist he made a
jokes about a joke about going to a
black neighborhood and um it's seeming
like planet of the apes right
and then it's just like edward edward
edward
um
so if again if that's the tip of the
iceberg you are rationally going to
think wow this guy has just been like
foaming at the mouth with racism for
years
and and that that it makes sense makes
perfect sense to take offense to that as
a black person or as any person
if you're familiar with much more of the
iceberg
as a lot of people probably are
and joe rogan has a lot of black fans
i don't think they're taking offense
because
uh
i mean they just they know his general
character
so well at this point
they're not getting new data about his
character right they know he's a
comedian that says says every curse word
makes fun of every group
so like imagine
this is this is very interesting imagine
you had never seen the show south park
and it's gone what over 20 seasons right
it's
similar to joe rogan in that they have a
[ __ ] ton of material
and you stitch together every joke at
black people's expense ever made on the
show south park and you have no other
familiarity with it
you are going to come away thinking how
the [ __ ] is this on tv is this show from
the [ __ ] jim crow south
like my god
now of course the rest of us that have
watched a lot of south park
we understand they make fun of everyone
they make fun of everyone right we've
seen the whole iceberg
that's what's happening to joe rogan
right now so yeah i assume a lot of
black people to the extent they're
seeing
a small sliver
of what he's done are taking offense but
again it is it is propaganda this is the
definition of propaganda
and
i think
that should be more widely understood
is there a difference in a white person
saying on a podcast versus a black
person
there is a difference in how it will be
received
most likely um
i mean i don't think you can
my listen my philosophy of communication
is that i can i'm never gonna ignore
what a person is trying to say
or or what a person means by what they
say what they're trying to communicate
even if they communicate it clumsily
yeah
i mean
if you were
like how would you approach talking to a
friend
right if they were communicating
something clumsily you would try to get
to the core of what they're saying right
that's
that's common sense
and
you know
i i really
i i understand that
you know i think right now if there were
a martian scientist that came to earth
and came to america
and saw that there was one and only one
word really that you can't say
and only people that are one color can't
say it and then people that are a
different color can say it
they would say okay
this is what people were talking about
when they said the homo sapiens have
these uh believe in magic right
the home they have a lot of superstition
and magical thinking and
taboos
and
you know like western anthropologists
will go to places where that have had no
contact with modernity for
you know hundreds of years and they'll
say oh isn't it amazing that the natives
here they think that if you
dance like this you'll bring the rain
right
and then they'll go back to the west and
think oh well we're super rational here
we don't we don't think anything crazy
we don't have any superstitious beliefs
except if you utter this magic word
you you like instantaneously do harm
right but only if you're one color
if you're another color you can say that
word
especially if you change the suffix of
it so to like a soft a rather than a
hard er then it's not as harmful right
that i'm sorry that is magical thinking
without the
explicit magic
unless you're a rapper of any ethnicity
right
because they get a pass for everything
which is now makes complete sense about
why you wanted to be a rapper
and you know like
frankly i've heard a lot a lot of groups
of young people like teenagers that are
not black but are maybe hispanic or
asian
and are from certain neighborhoods
uh say the n word
and use it colloquially like amongst
themselves in mixed race groups of
people like it's a america is a
complicated place
there's over 300 million people here
and
um
everyone has a different story and comes
from a different background
and i hate this like one size fits all
these one size fits all rules are so
ridiculous to me
did you see the spotify ceo daniel x uh
email out to all staff have you seen
this yet it only came out this morning
okay so it's a big big big long email
kind of
i understand your plight i very sorry
that you are going through this at this
difficult time
and then on one of the screenshots if we
believe in having an open platform as a
core value of the company then we must
also believe in elevating all types of
creators including those from
underrepresented communities and a
diversity of backgrounds we've been
doing a great deal of work in this area
already but i think we can do even more
so i am committing to an incremental
investment of 100 million dollars for
the licensing development and marketing
of music artists and songwriters and
audio content from historically
marginalized groups this will
dramatically increase our efforts in
these areas while some may want us to
pursue a different path i believe that
more speech on more issues can be highly
effective in improving the status quo
and enhancing the conversation
altogether i deeply regret that you are
carrying so much of this burden i also
want to be transparent in setting the
expectation that in order to achieve our
goal of becoming the global audio
platform these kinds of disputes will be
inevitable for me i come back to
centering on our mission of unlocking
the potential of human creativity and
enabling more than a billion people to
enjoy the work of what we think will be
more than 50 million creators that
mission makes these clashes worth the
effort so that is 100 million dollars
to historically marginalized groups
audio music and audio content what does
that actually mean
what does that mean a hundred they're
investing a hundred million dollars to
committing to an incremental investment
of 100 million dollars for the licensing
development and marketing of music
artists and songwriters and audio
content from historically marginalized
groups licensing development and
marketing okay that's interesting and
vague
but uh
i mean big picture they are standing up
for
intellectual diversity on their platform
and open discourse and free speech and i
think that's
uh they should be congratulated for that
they are they are a huge
i mean they're a huge player they're the
player in in the audio space and for
them to just
to not buckle under this pressure
is
a a really enormous achievement for
those of us that care about free speech
and open discourse they they should set
a precedent for other corporations
you know when spotify survives this
which i'm i'm quite certain they will
and people move on to the next
controversy
um
they will be seen i hope as a precedent
for how corporations
can
essentially not negotiate with like
quote-unquote terrorists so to speak
right like you don't
you you shouldn't negotiate with people
based on these
really ephemeral ephemeral kind of
outbursts of outrage
you can't be beholden to that as a
corporation compromise your mission
um presumably to push back that
presumably there could have been a thing
that joe could have said that would be
so reprehensible that he would deserve
being completely removed from the
platform he there could be something
that he could have said some
absolutely awful call for violence just
like an endless racial homophobic
misogyny whatever barrage and you go
okay yeah this this this is
unrecoverable i don't think that it's a
difference of kind i just think it's a
difference of degree and
yes i i would agree that spotify hasn't
caved as much as they could have done
but i've just checked jremising.com
113 episodes are missing from spotify
almost all of which were removed on
february 4th uh alex jones owen benjamin
theo vaughn uh two from my friend
michael mallis alex jones his second one
crystalia and the interesting thing is
that in
the statement from daniel elks ex daniel
x danny elec um he says that joe was the
one that selected the episodes
that really that really surprised me
first off because uh the episodes got
taken down before joe did a response or
before i found out about this response
and i mentioned i was like look just
straight up
think about the simplest solution to
this i can't remember what i said on a
podcast two months ago
there's no way that joe's gonna go um
let me remember yeah 845 912 like he's
not going to be able to go back like
some sort of rain man and be able to
remember all of the stuff that's
happened so i presumed that at the very
least it was
outsourced to a team and
more likely outsourced to an algorithm
that's maybe fed back up transcripts
that could have then been searched
through but there's some of the episodes
in there that have very very little to
do with anything but are critical of the
saudis and spotify is now pushing into
the saudi market there's some episodes
in there with people like crystalia who
although
may or may not there may be other stuff
in there but chris has had his own sort
of cancel culture thing occur recently
so the concern here is that this is a
well-timed smoke screen in order to be
able to take down a bunch of other
content that they're not happy with so
i'd agree with you when you say that
spotify hasn't caved as much as they
could but i also think that there is
something going on here whether that be
joe's behest or a spotify or a
collaboration between the two or maybe
the ufc has said uh we have an
incredibly [ __ ] diverse fighter
roster here like there's there's going
to be pressure from them too um
but there has been some concessions made
was my point
yeah that's a good point i revised my
my judgment there i think um
yeah it does i mean
this is what some people warned about
when joe rogan signed the spotify deal
um yep
all eggs in one basket
totally and
you know i i really
i don't
okay so i agree with your point that
there is something that is so over the
line that spotify would
be justified in taking it down
i can't imagine joe rogan saying
anything ever close to that line
um
and
you know this is the thing with free
speech
i think
because
the question is are we
are we debating over a principle
or are we just
do we all agree that censorship is okay
and just disagree about where the line
is
right so like all of us
i don't know anyone who is into
holocaust denial
or who is who is super upset if if a
hall a straight up holocaust denies
um goes down yeah yeah blog goes down
or someone who is you know actively
inciting
you know even worse someone who thinks
the holocaust didn't happen but wants it
to happen and is trying to get it to
happen
right like through their podcast
um like a modern day actual hitler
no one is going to be
too upset when that person
gets their podcast taken off spotify you
know after all again it is a private
company
if if it's
part of its values is that it doesn't
want to promote the holocaust which is
pretty understandable
um
it can act on that
so is it like
we're we're all drawing the line
somewhere between like holocaust denial
and like anti-vaxx information and some
of us are drawing it just like over here
and we're arguing about whether joe
rogan is in
the no-go zone
or are we actually arguing over
an actual principle
a principal disagreement about whether
these platforms should allow
a wide range of speech
well let's not forget that by the sounds
of things joe has taken down a chunk of
these
by his own choice and it's his library
man he gets to choose what he says and
he gets to choose what you listen to by
virtue of what he says and who he brings
on this is a this is something that i
think about all the time
every single decision that a podcaster
makes when they're having a conversation
is editorial
me deciding to push back or not push
back against something that you say
every time that i decide to either
fragment the conversation or i decide to
stay on the main trunk or i decide to
move on each one of those is an
editorial decision
the same goes for what i do and don't
say what i do and don't release i've
recorded podcasts previously that i
haven't released because i thought it
doesn't make the author look
tremendously good maybe they were having
an off day or they weren't quite right
or whatever so i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna put it out like it'll be it's not
because they've said something
catastrophic no one's ever come on and
been right yeah i've done the same thing
it's just not
interesting yeah okay so is it my duty
to release podcasts that i think are not
interesting well no probably not you're
asking me to probably lose some audience
in order to release what because of
freedom of speech it's not free it's not
my duty to release a boring podcast
so roll it forward from there it's not a
difference of kind it's just a
difference of degree and then when
you're talking about getting rid of
stuff from the past i'm sure there's
stuff that you've said in in the past
that was
clumsy and clunky and i really wish that
i'd said it differently or hadn't said
it or
whatever right and as you do more
content and as you do it more frequently
and as it's over a longer period of time
as well norms change
uh cultural values around what isn't
isn't acceptable change i mean the
n-word's been you know unacceptable for
a long time
that's probably fair to say but
well i mean
you know it wasn't that long ago that
people
were
somewhat likely to observe the
difference between using the word in
quotations and throwing it at someone i
mean even 10 years ago
i think people were more likely to
observe that distinction than they are
now
yeah i think that that's fair
i also think that there's like a
a comedian's trolley problem thing going
on
where
those guys that their job is to try and
push
the limits their job is to is to
genuinely try and take you past the
point at which you think i i cannot
believe that they've said this
and the problem is that when everything
is captured and then kept on the
internet for eternity
it's easier
for an audience to take something out of
context than it is to do it with a live
stand-up set that probably isn't even
recorded i found out only a couple of
weeks ago from a friend that's a
comedian in the uk that he records every
single one of his sets for precisely
this reason that if somebody complains
to the club and says this person was
saying whatever phobic or ism it is that
we want to throw at them they have the
recording so that's the degree of the
sort of damocles thing
the level of
protection
that comedians have
now or that they need to have in order
to keep themselves safe
in in the past two or three years the
big comedy clubs in new york have all
begun requiring that you put your phone
in a secured bag and turn it off or on
silent you know comedy seller in the
stand
before you go into the club because
comedians can't work under
surveillance comedy does not work under
surveillance i think
another thing people don't understand
about comedy is that comics don't know
which one of their jokes are which of
their jokes are going to be funny until
they tell them to an audience for the
first time
um they they have some sense
but
you know all of the
all of the netflix specials you see from
your favorite comics
were
[Music]
pared down from far more jokes
that
these comics tested in front of live
audience
in as an experiment in order to see
which ones were the funniest
and
and pare it down to those which
eventually make it into the netflix
special right
they don't know
and and the line between funny and
offensive is is is super thin right
and what's more
whatever you know something being taboo
is an element of it potentially being
funny it's not just that funny things
are often
dealing with taboo topics it's that
if there is a taboo topic
it is by definition
rife
with humor potential right like it's a
taboo is a constitutive element of humor
in our species that's just how our minds
work
so
in order for uh listen
we don't have to have stand-up comedy
most places in the world don't have
stand-up comedy okay
america does have stand-up comedy and i
think that's amazing i think that's one
of you know that's
one of the elements of our culture that
i most love
but the only way that it works
is if we allow people to approach taboo
subjects
to
find the line
by crossing it which is the only way to
find it
and to test things out right we could
become a country very easily that just
doesn't have stand-up comedy has no
robust stand-up scene
because we
because our culture shifts
that is a very real possibility there's
no there's no law that says your culture
has to be compatible with having a
robust stand-up comedy scene i think
that would be very sad if that happened
but we should we should view
we should view the uh the cultural
elements that allow for us to have good
comedy in this country
those are fragile those are things that
need to be defended their values that
need to be defended or else they'll go
away they're not something we should
take for granted
how much of this is
envy
by the mainstream media at someone that
shouldn't have risen up to the level of
cultural influence and clout that they
have
yeah i think i think a good amount of it
is that i mean
the existence of joe rogan as
such a towering figure
is
in some way a condemnation of
the failures of mainstream media
i'm not saying if mainstream media were
better joe rogan would be a nobody it's
not what i'm saying
he's funny
he he would have a huge audience
regardless
but
he
he is
as popular as he is
he has the insane degree of popularity
that he does
because he's willing to have
conversations that the mainstream media
rules out okay so like for instance the
idea that kovid
kr saras kovetu leaked from the lab a
couple miles away
that was constantly tinkering with
things extremely close to sars kova ii
the closest viral ancestors to tsar's
kova ii
in the world okay
like on its face plausible
not crazy should be looked into
and when fauci initially called the
meeting in late january early february
to discuss this with the top virologists
many of them
thought it probably came from the lab
right
okay
the whole media basically decides this
is conspiracy this is misinformation
and many people
um you know uh
had incentives to
to kind of kind of take that line
who is the person in society that's
gonna really have that conversation
in a way that isn't
um merely finger pointing and point
scoring against the left but is truly
open-minded to
to evidence joe rogan right he is going
to fill that gap
when cnn and msnbc
decide that
lab leak is bunk
um
joe rogan's going to have that
conversation and he's going to have it
in a long exploratory way
um
tucker carlson is going is merely going
to use it as
a cudgel against democrats in the left
and you know flash forward to
two years later
where
you pretty much have the top scientists
now saying you know
it's now like 50 50 between lab leak and
natural emergence
and we're taking this seriously and the
world health organization takes it
seriously
and fauci says he can't rule it out now
has changed his position
like that gets vindicated as a
legitimate hypothesis
and rogan
is the kind of person that would be
systematically open to that when the
mainstream said it was a false
conspiracy theory
and that's why
he has such a large audience is because
the mainstream media fails in those
kinds of ways
rogan is playing in the vacuum that they
have left yeah i would absolutely agree
that would be the the short way to say
what i just took
but the point is
his success
is a finger pointed at mainstream media
saying you guys are [ __ ] up
mainstream media doesn't want to admit
that they would much rather believe
his success is an element of him being
able to weaponize racism misogyny and
homophobia and feed red meat to a
bigoted audience
that's the way that they can preserve
their image of saying no there's nothing
wrong with us we're doing an amazing job
we are killing it
joe rogan is simply able to weaponize
the worst in our culture and build a
following as a result
that's a much more friendly narrative
here's the thing i think that people
need to remember as well for all that
joe is probably the single most powerful
media personality on the planet who
commands you know nation's worth of
plays on a weekly basis
he's just a guy there are no rules for
how you're supposed to do sense making
outside of the institutions there is no
uh operating procedure manual that me
and you are supposed to adhere to
the
rules of what we do and don't say the
cadence of the conversation the type of
the conversation everything that we do
whether we keep in touch afterwards
whether we don't whether we prep before
whether we don't whether we all of that
is
it purely exists through the evolution
of people that have done this there's no
playbook that anybody follows so the
same thing occurs for what happens if a
video of you saying some things that you
regret pops up so for someone to say
that joe should or shouldn't have done
whatever well hang in a second
you weren't saying this about the way
that he conducted himself on his show or
the way that he named his show or his
artwork or his show notes or the links
that he puts out or how he promotes it
or anything else
joe is a guy
who is leading the pack in forging an
entire new world he is failing in public
and learning out loud right every time
that he has a conversation it's the
first time he's had that exact
conversation with that exact guest at
that particular time so
every single one of his errors is out
there for people and maybe he'll look
back and think do you know what it is
i'm really glad that i did those two
apologies maybe at the time it looked a
little bit to people like i was rolling
over or like i was getting pressure from
spotify but i know in my heart of hearts
that it's because i felt x or y or z or
whatever like
all of these editorial decisions that
joe gets to make that his
he can choose and if you love him for
the show then as far as i'm concerned
you know back him like i i back him for
what it is that he does because of all
of the
the insights and the um enjoyment and
pleasure and curiosity and intellectual
satisfaction that i've got from his show
i trust that joe is doing the thing that
he thinks is right for what it is that
he's going to do
right
no i i agree uh i mean i think i should
just say
um if i'm going to level any criticism
of joe rogan's show i think i i strongly
disagree with the perspectives expressed
by his anti-vaxx doctors
i i do think it's misinformation i know
people roll their eyes
i think um
at that word now because it's it's used
so much
um
but listen
the vaccines
are safe and effective right
and
i think he should
do
more prep when he has those kinds of
controversial guests on
um to be able to
sort of challenge them on factual
elements now of course if you're talking
to someone who
like did early work on the concept of mr
mrnas and is deep in the weeds
uh it's very difficult there's basically
no amount of prep that you can do that's
going to mean that you can battle back
right
um
still you know it's it's it makes sense
to do as much prep as as you can
um and
and also to have people with the
opposite perspective on and listen
that's exactly basically what he said
he's going to do in his apology and
and so you know if i can level any
criticism at the show it'd be that
but that is a real far cry from from the
idea that you know it should be
cancelled
plus it's taken down it's the thing that
he's suggested that he's going to try
and rectify i think the best way to do
that the best solution that i could see
around those sort of topics is to do
what he did with tim paul and the and
jack dorsey you know bring bring bring
people on and mediate
um rather than having two different
sorts of conversations you know here's
one here's another because the bottom
line is that certain
types of talking points are more
limbically hijacking and more seductive
to people than others and
sam harris talks about uh 9 11 truthers
that there's always a
degree of freedom on a conversation
where someone says well what about the
10 000 ballots that were hidden in
virginia or what about the fact that
steel only burns did you know about this
man from this particular principality of
the fire system that said that he was in
there five nights before like there's
just there's too many degrees of freedom
in there and you really need a
specialist
um and if you have somebody who is uh
pushing the boundaries on either side
pushing the boundaries of legitimacy or
of truthfulness
they can hack
people's desire to believe in one
particular narrative or another
and if you have somebody else who is
less prepared to play fast and loose
with the truth or their uh general
overall narrative is less seductive um
you really just need them in a room at
the same time so that the person can
push back the specialist can go against
the specialist and i think you're right
i think that joe said look i i've not
been in this position before i i didn't
really know that this was an issue but
i've accepted that it is one and moving
forward i'm going to try and do
something different i think
you know from my side as a podcaster who
tries to put out a lot of content and
does it you know four or five hours a
week
i think that that's
the best that like joe could have done
yeah no i agree i think the apology was
great and i i can't imagine
thinking that that that apology came
across as groveling or or submitting to
something he shouldn't have been
submitting to i really couldn't disagree
with that take more
um
you know i
i've been in the position where i've
said things on my podcast or i've had a
guest
that i didn't push back on enough
on certain points that i later found out
to be
that that i really should have pushed
back on this this kind of thing
it really is inevitable in the course of
a long
podcasting career and that doesn't mean
you shouldn't rectify it you absolutely
should rectify it if you want to keep
anything like a kind of trusting
relationship with your audience
um
but
you know like i can't help but come back
to this point about the massive double
standards that
joe rogan is is operating under as
opposed to
you know people in cable news well you
say that but i think especially with the
second issue that we're coming up
against if there was a
super cut of
uh
someone from cnn or fox news saying the
n word over and over and over and over
again
i'd i think that they would have
similar or maybe even
worse repercussions than joe's going
through
so i mean so it's different because the
super cut would have to be cut from
their own show that we've all been
watching for years right the same is
true of joe though
right so but but but it would have to
not be a surprise it would have to just
be
it would have to be that they've been
saying this
and it was fine
the network didn't care
until they saw it back to back to back
the reason being what i'm saying the
reason being that a big chunk of the uh
clips that are used by joe are when this
the show was so small
that
relatively
no one was watching compared with how
many people watch now whereas the
presumption around mainstream media is
that it's kind of been well it's
probably been probably been going down
uh but that a similar number of people
could have found a problem with it in
the past whereas with joe it's like um
this is a
a smoking gun that nobody was actually
able to see this is like secret
information whereas if it was cnn or fox
news it's obvious that it's not because
it's been on on cable for ages yeah i
understand what you mean right i mean
you know i i come back to the joyride
case for example like
they've
you know she had a blog in in like the
2000s where she said gay men
tend to like underage boys and that she
was she said she was quote homophobic
and
um she was opposed you know against gay
marriage
and then when she got called out on it
she claimed that her blog had been
hacked she said oh i i didn't maybe
someone else hacked my blog
and then
people confirmed that her blog was not
hacked at all and she said those things
and she she finally came out and stopped
lying and said okay i'm sorry my views
have changed
i've been hurt
she's on msnbc no one gives a [ __ ]
you know and and joe rogan his
infractions were not actually expressing
bigoted beliefs this is this is what
gets me about it it's he didn't say
black people were less
he didn't say
he didn't express
a belief
in an explicit way
like joy reid did he said the n word
which a lot of people take offense to
obviously
and he made a joke
about going into black neighborhoods
right
um
and
i think there still is a huge double
standard here
i think there is a people are out to get
joe in a way
that they can view you know joy reid's
comments as oh she she doesn't she sees
why they're wrong now and
blah blah blah but joe
joe that's who he is
you know tip of the iceberg
and
and so yeah i mean
i i really do think that there is a
double standard here because of how many
people
want joe to be cancelled to begin with
if it wasn't for the fact that he was on
spotify exclusively i don't think that
this would have happened either i think
that there's low-key resentment around
the fact that he garnered so much
support and so much money for doing
something
and the show since he's been on spotify
no one knows the exact figures but
apparently it's got even bigger
which again is a kick in the teeth to
mainstream media and then finally what
you have by it being a single platform
exclusive as opposed to just an rss feed
that gets distributed around the
internet you have a point of leverage
and this was the concern that people had
that by being on one platform you don't
need to pressure joe rogan you can
pressure the platform
and that was the concern but i think if
he wasn't on spotify i don't think that
this i think this just washes through
and perhaps that explains maybe this is
the first time
that that video that n-word video has
done the rounds
uh since joe's been on just spotify and
since it's been the case that like the
the cultural algorithm was primed by the
previous apology and the fact that the
news
stories were already talking about him
you know the cnn horse pace horsty
wormer thing last year kind of that
kicks the ball rolling it's into the
mainstream
sort of populist his idea it's like
boomer territory now okay then we go
again then we go again then we go again
and now it just picks up picks up picks
up yeah i do think that is the dynamic
and
listen i mean i hope
people don't
i think you know the arguments for free
free and open discourse and allowing
more speech than you would tend to
are perpetually under attack
throughout history
free speech is almost never the popular
position if you look historically
because censorship is just too
attractive
us versus them they are the enemy
destroy them don't allow them to speak
that is always
that always has a kind of strength
but
you know i think that it is really
important
to
remind people
of the benefits of allowing more speech
than you you would be moved to right the
the point of free speech isn't to
it's not free speech for things you like
it's free speech precisely for things
you don't like and think are dangerous
um often because those sometimes those
ideas turn out to be right
um as joe pointed out there were a lot
of things that were once labeled
misinformation about kovid
that are no longer labeled
misinformation about covid such as that
cloth masks don't work
that you can get a breakthrough
infection
all these things were at one point
considered dangerous misinformation
right
and the truth is the people that
are tasked with determining what is
dangerous misinformation and what what
is not
they are fallible human beings they're
human beings that make mistakes
or they're experts that can operate
under an incentive system
um
a politicized incentive system that
leads them to bend the truth
right so so for example
you know anthony fauci
has
fully admitted now
that
when he talks about public health
information
he is not always honest sometimes he
tells the public
what he thinks it's most useful for them
to hear rather than what's true
he has admitted this this is his problem
it's just like his philosophy of public
health messaging
um you know if he think when he he said
that when only 50 of people were
indicating they would take a vaccine
he said the number we needed for herd
immunity was like 70. and when 60
said they would take the vaccine he
pushed it up to like 80. right so he's
he's trying to meet us where we're at
which is not honest that's a not not an
honest way of of approaching the issue
and you could debate whether it's good
or bad
um but the idea that you can't challenge
anything that is officially labeled
misinformation
uh that that is a very dangerous idea
for our society because
um there's gonna a lot of misinformation
is gonna turn out to be true
being able to talk and think about a lot
of misinformation is is going to be very
important
and for better or for worse
a lot of people already believe things
that are untrue
and simply censoring them simply taking
them down from platforms is not going to
persuade people that believe false
things into believing the truth
talking about
officially permitted
and strange incentive structures
something i've been thinking about for a
while is whether or not the um high
water mark of the robin d'angelos and
the ibramex candies has sort of crested
now and then scott alexander put a post
out uh why i suck uh he put this out the
other day about how woke social justice
issues just aren't very cool anymore so
he said while everyone else is freaking
out about wokeness i'm starting to feel
like all my friends are anti-woke who's
woke anymore are there really still woke
people other than all corporations every
government agency and all media
properties i mean those don't count any
real people i guess i know one or two
sjws but i also know one or two
catholics it doesn't mean that they're
not the intellectual equivalent of an
out of place artifact so the question is
like do you think that we're past peak
woke or have we still got further to go
i do think we're past peak woke
um but we may also still have further to
go i mean peak woke was in 2020.
um so for example
at the height of the george floyd
protests
and the riots
can you possibly imagine a com company
like spotify
when pressured because one of their
their biggest podcast
has a cut away you know cut
cut up of the n-word
they would buckle under any
racism-related pressure in june july
2020.
that
you know really remember what that was
like
um
the the very fact that they haven't
fully buckled
is proof that we are past peak woke
that we are not as
woke as we were in in 2020.
um of course
2020 was like a massive spike in woke so
it's possible that it sort of goes like
this and then comes down a little bit
but there's still a whole lot for a long
time so i um
i really don't know i i don't tend to
make predictions because it's very
difficult to predict where the culture
is going
but you know
woke ideas definitely have staying
powers in the universities
at the very least
and that probably ensures that they will
they'll be around for some time
but the influence they have on the rest
of the culture is really
that is for
us as a culture to sort of collectively
decide
right like
how much influence do we want
evangelical christianity to have over
the rest of us that is
very much up to
we the people how much influence do we
want woke to have over the rest of us
again very much
up to we the people and how we
how we talk how we act
and uh
you know
what
content we allow on spotify these are
all decisions that are a part of
what the trend is going to become
so
if this is something you care about
and it it's something i care about i
think it's bad when you have
you know maybe
at most like three or four percent of
americans or probably truly woke in the
sense that people think
of that term
i think it's a problem when you have
that
kind of fringe philosophy like that
uh you know take over
corporate america or at the at the very
least corporate america feels they have
to pay homage to it
that's been the relationship of
christianity to it to a lot of
i mean woke has more influence than
christianity in in in corporate america
and
you know probably still
what 40 percent of americans are like
evangelical christians
right whereas maybe three or four
percent of americans are really really
woke
in the sense that they
you know they they refer to hispanic
people as like latinx and stuff like
that
um so
groups can have power completely
disproportionate to
the
their actual numbers
um social and cultural power i mean
and
uh
you know it is very much up to the rest
of us to defend whatever values we have
so that
small minorities with with very muscular
ideologies
don't take over every institution that
you care about
there's a
barber pole model of cool that's
happening here as well i think so when
your uh uncle on facebook starts being
anti-woke
that's when you know it's probably
gotten too mainstream to be cool to do
it anymore and the same thing goes for
your aunt if she's the one that's being
woke if she's the one that's tweeting
about ibra max candy so it's like when
stuff gets co-opted by the mainstream
the fact that this is an underground
subservient movement that
falls away and i think that
people need to concede that a good
amount of what was seductive from the
woke side and from the anti-work side
was that this felt like some sort of
grassroots movement like i am at the
absolute tip of the spear of what's
happening with the culture and that was
what probably seduced a lot of people
into being a part of it on both sides
yeah i think that is true
at the same time
you know i feel like woke has
been
i don't know you know like elizabeth
warren was saying latinx
and that was
i don't know that's fairly mainstream
right like i feel like it's been a while
now is what i'm saying that
woke has been
not merely an underground
counter-revolutionary if you will
movement but
has been the language of many elites and
um
and i'm not sure you know i i i do hope
you're right
uh and i'm not really sure
to what degree auntie woke
you know your uncle is your uncle is
auntie woke i think um
i feel like your uncle is maybe a trump
supporter
and that overlaps with auntie woke but
it's the dynamics are very tough to sort
out but
one thing i i hope is true
and i think is true is that
you know when your kindergarten teacher
is woke
it's not going to be cool
and that's already kind of happening and
i think there is this
there are basically like two very lazy
assumptions that people on the far left
make about the demography and direction
of the country which is like
we're getting browner
and blacker as a population and less
white
and therefore democrats are gonna like
win everything
just based on demographics if we just
like
keep going this direction we don't have
to do anything we don't have to persuade
people we don't have to win people over
we don't have to win swing voters we're
just gonna win based on demographics a
ridiculous notion ridiculous idea
and it's also by the way equally
ridiculous for people on the far right
to fear that because the share of white
america is shrinking
that like
uh you know like their ideas are gonna
evaporate right
um i would like their ideas to evaporate
by the way but
um it's not gonna happen by demographics
alone
and and then
this idea that like
the younger generations will just
definitely be woke
and even woker i'm not sure how true
that is
because to the extent that woke wokeness
becomes
more and more
has more and more influence
at the level of like
k-12
the more and more that your health
teacher is woke and like your gym
teacher is woke the less and less cool
it will be to be woke because you're not
even auntie the teachers you're a
teacher's pet
so in the long run i think
a movement like this can't
it can't last forever
and it won't last forever and it's it's
not inevitable
and people should
feel uh people should
push themselves to be
as courageous as they can
in
in voicing their own thoughts even if
those thoughts
are potentially
cancelable and as hopeful as they can
as well sure because
there's a few fragilities a few holes in
the sphere that is wokeness one of them
being that as mainstream adoption
increases the coolness of being a part
of some sort of revolutionary ideal
starts to fade away
another one is that intersectionality is
inherently self-defeating because it
starts to slice itself into ever smaller
and smaller slivers the only way that
you bind the in group together is over
mutual hatred of an out group and the
purity spiral means that you need to
continue to find more and more people to
point the circular firing squad out and
say well they're they're no longer that
pure person that they should have been
anymore so now we round we shave a
little bit off the side we shave a
little bit off the side and it just gets
more and more pure as it spirals all the
way up but i think if
if anything from me one of the main
lessons i've learned around the response
to wokeness is the power of comedians
and ridicule and this is interesting
when we tie it back to comedians that
are doing long form podcasts and stuff
like that and the danger that uh comedic
trolley problem that
ridiculing something is one of the most
powerful tools that you have
to push back against it because you make
it so toxic and contaminated that nobody
wants to do it nobody wants to be
anywhere near the thing which is
socially
completely toxic to be associated with
that's the best enforcement mechanism
you could have you could try and
litigate it you can bureaucracy you can
do whatever information campaign you can
but if some cool funny people make jokes
out of it
that's it
cut off at the knees right totally
and um
i mean i think woke
woke and far right have have suffered a
lot of ridicule
and um you know that that's part of how
comedians participate in
the
healthy fight against extremism is by
making fun of ridiculous people
and that's something joe rogan
has done a lot and
we i think we owe him a debt of
gratitude as a culture for being
one of the biggest comedians doing that
as far as your other point about
intersectionality
i read a
article i think the other day i think
was from the root and it said straight
black men
are the white men of black people
[Laughter]
like this is intersectional logic right
this is
intersectional death spiral
is you just
the whole philosophy is white men are
evil
and almost it's almost like
the opposite too it's like the notion of
evil
only makes sense in the context of
oppression like there are no other kinds
of evil that people really care about
it's like
evil is whiteness and whiteness is evil
and so in order to describe something
else evil we have to almost talk about
it in terms of
white men
it's like that's the barometer now men
are the white men of black people
it's amazing
um it's a very
like it's it's it's one of these
ideologies where it has a hammer and
everything looks like a nail
and the only hammer it has is your
identity
that's all it's about
and um there's so much more to being a
human being in this world than
as as my friend camille foster would say
the shape and shade of your genitals
um
and so it's
that's why i think that that's one
reason why i don't think it it has
that much staying power
in the in the very long run
but uh it will probably always
be around
it does feel like the snake that eats
its own tail it's always felt like this
even when i spoke to douglas murray on
his madness of crowds thing which is
what two two and a half years ago now
something like that
it felt like that at the time that it's
inherently fragile
and
the thing that i thought back then and
the thing that i think now because i'm
big into existential risk and i'm
concerned about where we're going as a
civilization on a species-wide level you
know agi bio weapons natural pandemics
those sort like genuine civilization
ending things
every single thought minute that is
taken up by a a capable smart person
that is spent working out whether men or
men and women are women or not
is one that isn't spent working out how
we get through the next 100 years
without permanently curtailing our
civilization's ability to reach its full
genetic potential
like
galaxy colonizing multi-planetary
species with trillions and trillions and
trillions of lives living the type of
happiness that no one has ever yet even
got close to touching
and yet we are getting caught up
asking questions
about whether men and men and women are
women or not or whether or not you're
the white man of the rap game
yeah i mean i'm skeptical of the
galaxy
tech utopia
what's that thing
i i think that they're
i assume there are limits
practical limits to what we will be able
to do with technology
um
that there are things we conceive that
we will not be able to practically do i
don't know what that what those things
are
but i tend to think that that is true
there is a guy at the moment who is
working on
well the book explains it we could get
to the nearest star system the nearest
planet of the nearest star system that
looks like it might be able to be
habitable for life within 500 years
from now
with the technology that we have
currently now the problem that we have
is that genetically we are really really
not built for space flight we get all
sorts of things that go wrong with us if
we're up there so that's what he's
working on he's working on trying to
genetically modify humans so that we
could better survive space flight
radiation
zero gravity bond density giving no
one's given birth in space
i asked him whether or not he knew if
christopher mason's the author i asked
him whether he knew if anyone had sex in
space uh and he just sort of gave me
this look i was like that
looks a lot like a yes christopher uh
but
yeah i i would say
the one the one uh
big hole in
we can go and colonize the galaxy is if
we can do it and we arrived relatively
late
during the universe's maturity
why aren't we seeing other galaxies that
appear to be colonized by civilizations
as well so that is a good question but
we don't know how rare earth is and this
gets into fermi paradox territory
i think that we can all accept that
even if we don't go multi-planetary
across the galaxy
there are a lot of lives that should be
still to come
whether we leave this planet or not
whether elon even just gets us to mars
or not and if that's the case there are
some challenges that we're going to face
on an existential threat level
even just staying on earth let alone
going elsewhere
those are things that are really
important plus tons of other stuff that
are really important i agree with the
existential threat
point that that we don't spend enough
time
really thinking about how to prevent
these things
i mean but but let me just come back to
like the tech tech utopia thing or the
fixing all the biological problems with
humans that don't allow us to
survive long enough in space
um
[Music]
last year i had i had a cough that was
lasting for
for weeks
so i went to the doctor
and the doctor was very nice he gave me
a free x-ray gave me
looked at me blah blah
and he diagnosed me with a cough
and he said would you would you like me
to give you any medicine and i was
i was trying to record songs i was
trying to record podcasts i was
desperate to get rid of this [ __ ]
cough
and i said give me all the medicine
and he and he basically
gave it to me knowing it wouldn't work i
knew it wouldn't work
there's no cure there's no cure for a
simple cough
it's not bacterial necessary like simple
bronchitis
um you know like over-the-counter cough
medicine actually doesn't work in
meta-analysis like robitussin certainly
doesn't work on me
as an n of one
um
you know antibacterial
steroids for inflammation
nothing
i just drank tea for a month and
eventually it went away my point is that
there is no [ __ ] cure for the common
cough yet after
thousands of years of human trying to do
medicine and hundreds of years of us
doing it scientifically
and
the lesson in that is that
certain problems are way
harder
than other problems and we're not always
good at predicting which problems are
the hard ones we put a man on the moon
we haven't cured the common cough
cancer is another one that is turning
out to be
extremely hard
um
where where other things we just you
know
people can live their whole lives with
hiv now
you know what if the problem of
you know immortality or really extending
the human life ban span turns out to be
a sort a problem like the common cough
where it it just is
this like you can describe it as an
engineering problem
you can describe it you can understand
the problem and there seems to be a
theoretical simple solution if we could
only just do this we could only just do
that but then a thousand years from now
we're still you know we're at most
living to like
110 or maybe 120.
and it turns out to just be something
that's actually too hard to solve all at
one go and we just make incremental
progress kind of for a long time but
then maybe plateau
i don't know
i think that you're right we are not
particularly good at working out which
problems are the difficult ones and it
is surprising that we've achieved so
such things
very easily and other ones are still
there as these glaring problems i think
i'm more of a
both a techno uh theorist and an
optimist at the same time that the
potentials that we're going to get
exponentially as we get better ai as we
have more powerful computers as we have
better programming and better
understanding of everything
is going to open up opportunities that
we can't foresee and it's also going to
create challenges that we also can't
foresee and it's balancing those two
things together but uh toby ord's the
precipice which is my favorite book an
existential risk unbelievable and
there's this
big [ __ ] risk at the bottom that's
called unknown unknowns
and
that's the one that in pretty much
everything it's
so many degrees of freedom away from
where you are now or degrees of
separation that you just don't know what
the problem is going to be and for
everything that you open up there's a
potential that you might decide to pick
a ball out of the urn of potentials
which is really big and black and scary
and if it's one of the black balls that
you pick out that you've tried to fix a
problem by creating something that
causes a much worse problem and that's
something that all of these are known
unknowns right as we continue to roll
forward so i think that you're right
there are
there are challenges that open up um
and challenges that are much more
insurmountable than we think
uh however i would i feel uh hopeful at
fixing problems my concern is the
creation of new ones
well yeah i agree with you there
coleman hughes ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
music and the youtube and the writing
what's best where should they go
follow me at cold man with an x in the
middle c-o-l-d-x-m-a-n
on twitter
uh same thing on spotify you can listen
to my music check out the song and the
video on youtube it's called blasphemy
and go to my website colemanhughes.org
where you can support my podcast or you
can just listen for free on wherever you
listen to podcasts called conversations
with coleman so thanks man what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace